la première question qu'on le groupe
l'est républicain est posée par monsieur
christian jacob
merci madame la présidente
jeudi dernier c'est jouer une scène
absolument surréaliste dans laquelle le
président de la république il faut bien
le dire ne s'est pas grandie nous avons
découvert avec consternation
un tweet de son grand communicant qui
nous annonçait je le cite le président
chez lucette à vandoeuvre madame brochet
puisque c'est son nom a donc accueilli
le président de la république soit
disant à l'improviste chez elle avec une
brochette de ministres et d'élus pour
une visite faite à l'improviste
madame brochen a vu arriver au préalable
les agents de l'elysée pour lui indiquer
les questions quel régal
chez shell shell ne devra sa carène
ensuite les agents de la mairie
socialiste sont venus faire le ménage
fournir les fleurs le café l'état les
souks ou et sans doute les petites
cuillères et le président de la
république devait lui découvrir à
l'occasion de cette visite inopinée la
situation des retraités un débile allons
sans émouvoir avec beaucoup de
compassion mais le pot-aux-roses a été
découvert tout cela était totalement
faux totalement fabriquées c'était une
opération montée préparer jusque dans
les moindres détails
monsieur le premier ministre je vous le
dit les yeux dans les yeux
arrêtez de prendre les français pour des
imbéciles
et la mauvaise farce ne s'arrête pas là
paniqué que vous êtes à cinq semaines
des élections régionales
vous annoncez que vous allez rembourser
les impôts locaux à des centaines de
millions de milliers de retraités sans
avoir de bases légales pour le faire
monsieur le premier ministre vous ne
ferez jamais oublier que vous êtes le
gouvernement des impôts et des taxes en
tous genres comment pouvez vous osez
dire que les impôts baissent alors que
le taux des prélèvements obligatoires ne
baissent pas quand allez vous comprendre
que les français ne supportent plus vos
petites manoeuvres mais il ne vous n'y
portent plus monsieur le premier
ministre
merci monsieur jacob la parole est à
monsieur le premier ministre
1 votre calme pour écouter le premier
ministre merci mes chers collègues
merci madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le
président jacob ce que les français ne
supportent plus c'est votre comportement
et c'est ce type de questions
la france comme bien d'autres pays est
confronté à des défis redoutables
le rendez vous climatique à paris qui
doit être un succès et la déclaration
franco-chinoise entre les deux
présidents chinois et français permet de
préparer ce rendez vous la france est
confrontée comme d'autres pays aux défis
terroristes ce qui nécessite de l'action
et du sérieux
la france comme l'europe sont confrontés
aux défis des réfugiés ce qui nécessite
de l'action au niveau européen une
politique migratoire maîtriser la france
est confrontée bien sûr au défi qui est
celui de la croissance et de l'emploi
et c'est le sens de notre politique la
france est confrontée depuis des années
et vous y porter une responsabilité tout
à fait écrasante à des déficits trop
élevés
un endettement que vous nous avez laissé
un niveau de chômage qui est un niveau
insupportable pour beaucoup de nos
compatriotes
et puis bien sûr un niveau d'impôt qui
lui aussi est insupportable enfin la
france est confrontée parfois un niveau
du débat public et politique qui est
insupportable pour tous ceux qui aiment
la république et la démocratie
alors chacun monsieur le président dans
son rôle
nous le gouvernement nous gouvernerons
jusqu'au bout dans l'intérêt des
français et à l'opposition des trousses
d'être sérieuse elle est vraiment à la
hauteur des responsabilités plutôt que
d'être dans l'anecdote dans l' attaque
stérile dans la propositions absurdes
comme celles de nicolas sarkozy dans un
comportement
toi yable que vous donnez aux français
soyons à la hauteur de la tolga et au
fond à la tente d'un grand pays comme le
nôtre vous monsieur jacob
vous avez encore quelques efforts
décidément à faire merci la parole